- [Mark] All right, Joy.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Joy, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from, originally?
- [Joy] I'm from Ohio, Dayton, Ohio.
- [Mark] And tell me about
your family and your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were a kid?
- [Joy] Yeah. Well, I started out
livin' with my grandmother,
who I thought was my mom, 'til she died.
Then I started livin' with my mom,
who I thought was my cousin.
From then, 4 to 17, I was
molested on a daily basis,
three family members. A
pastor. I got married.
- [Mark] Pastor as well?
- Yeah. I got married, had
two children by a married man.
That ended. Then I got married again.
This was a real thug type of
guy. Real penitentiary type.
And I thought he was a big dope dealer,
and I was fascinated
with just, his lifestyle.
But then I found out, he
had a big habit, to crack.
And he had relapsed and he
didn't tell me none of that.
So, found out he was doin' all
kinda stuff to get his dope.
But he was on the down
low, that was the ultimate.
- [Mark] So he was dating guys as well,
or having sex with guys.
- To get money. Big money.
- [Mark] Oh, he was getting paid for it?
- Oh yeah.
- [Mark] All right.
- So, I asked him for my money back,
'cause I was the type of woman,
any money that came to me workin',
social security, or whatever,
I would give to my man.
And I wanted to leave. He
didn't want me to leave,
he wanted to tell the
truth, but I have found out,
so I didn't wanna know the truth,
whatever he called the truth.
And so, he gave me his
dope. He took dope out,
hit the dope, made a pipe, just amazed me,
and offered it to me, and just was stuck.
And I got upset, took it,
and calmed myself on it.
Just smoke it, smoke it up.
(breathing quickly)
That way he ain't got no dope left,
he gon' have no money, you know, anything.
Little did I know, two weeks later,
I was chasing the same shit.
And it's been since 2000
that I been struggling.
I'm at my lowest today.
I'm literally homeless.
And I'm doing any and
everything to survive.
That's my story.
- [Mark] What kinda stuff
do you have to go through
just to make money?
- Steal. Sell my body.
Negotiate my morals.
And it's not always for dope.
Sometimes it's to eat,
sometimes it's to have
a roof over my head,
even if it's just a tent.
(traffic whirring in background)
It don't just be for dope.
It be for everything.
I'm livin' to use, and I'm usin' to live.
That's my story.
- [Mark] And do you have children?
- It's two. They're grown.
- [Mark] You have the
two kids that you had
with the married man?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You raised them?
- No, my daughter stayed with my sister,
up until the addictions started happenin'.
But my son was a ride or die 'til the end.
- [Mark] He what?
- My son was with me 'til the very end.
He had to let me go,
'cause I kept gettin' us in predicaments
where we had to move,
had to move, had to move.
And at one point, I didn't
find a place soon enough,
so he needed to stay with my parents,
and the anger started and since then-
- [Mark] Had you ever used
drugs before your husband?
It was just that one time got you hooked?
- I was 37 years old when I
started, when that happened.
- [Mark] And you haven't
been able to stop since?
- I had two or three
years, couple of times.
But it's what I choose.
- [Mark] You relapse?
- It's what I choose.
- [Mark] What do you think
people don't understand
about the power of crack or addiction?
- That it's really a disease,
it's really a disease.
- [Mark] It's not a
decision you're making?
- No. Not anymore.
- [Mark] It's not a bad decision-
- You start off makin' a decision.
- [Mark] Yeah. The first
time is maybe a decision,
but after that, it
becomes beyond your power.
- You don't have more.
You don't have a decision.
There are times when I can go, shoot,
maybe two or three months,
and I'm cool, I'm cool.
And all of a sudden,
I can get a urge that's
beyond the phenomenon,
or craving, that obsession
that, I mean, it's beyond it.
It's beyond it, it's
like, I gotta do anything.
So I've been going to mental
hospitals too, because,
I get to thinkin' about suicide,
'cause I'm tired of livin'
dirty, and nasty, and secretive.
I'm tired of bein'
laughed at, and put down.
(hands rubbing)
- [Mark] Do you have any friends?
- I just met one that I had
long time ago, in Compton.
He's really old, and I didn't
know where he had went,
and I just seen him, it's
been maybe three years now.
He said he got an apartment
through the VA in Radier.
So, he's offered me to
take a shower and eat,
and lay down and get some
rest. (laughs softly)
So that's who I was talkin' to
when I was cross the street.
- [Mark] Where do you sleep?
Where'd you sleep last night?
- Last night at a church.
I go to churches that is pretty
lit up and have security,
'cause they are huge.
The one where Farrah Fawcett
funeral was, the real big one.
But it's scary anywhere.
- [Mark] What kinda bad stuff
has happened to you out here?
- The robbin', just having
you do the sexual acts,
and not payin' you the money,
throwing you out of a car.
Throwing you out of a car. Lied on.
- [Mark] Then after a few weeks of this,
the shame becomes-
- Unbearable.
- [Mark] Another thing
that makes you use more.
- Yep. And the guilt.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Do you have hope of
getting out, permanently?
- I feel like, if there is
a way, then it'll happen.
But I'm not tryna make it happen no more.
Because I can't do, thank you,
I can't do for me, what I
feel like only God can do.
And I feel like God is
sayin', until I can say no,
this is the decision I gotta
make, and I gotta stick to it.
Only he can keep me, but
I gotta wanna be kept.
And I'm not there yet.
- [Mark] What's the most important lesson
you think you've learned in your life?
- Don't judge people.
'Cause I called my
husband a crack head hoe,
and that's what I became.
And now I understand.
- [Mark] Would you describe
yourself as depressed?
- [Joy] Yeah, I'm manic depressed.
'Cause I'm mad, 'cause I understand,
so I don't have anymore
excuses. (laughs softly)
So that makes me angry.
So when I do drugs, I don't feel anything.
I know it, 'cause our
problems don't go no where,
they don't be waitin' on us.
They be right in the head.
- [Mark] And you were good friends with
one of my favorite-
- [Joy] Yeah. (laughs)
- [Mark] People I've interviewed,
- [Joy] Right.
- [Mark] Alicia.
- [Joy] Yeah.
- [Mark] Did you guys
used to talk about your addiction?
- [Joy] Yeah, we lived in the
same room in the Weingart,
and it's like, people just
allowin' things to happen.
'Cause they smokin' and
everything in the Weingart,
and the caseworkers, and so forth, know.
- [Mark] But for a woman
who's addicted to crack,
you end up, (sighs deeply)
you're at the mercy
of these men down here that will just
do everything and anything, right?
- [Joy] And anything.
- [Mark] They don't care about age,
they don't care about pregnancies,
they don't care about
black eyes or broken bones.
- [Joy] And most them are down, though.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Joy] Most of 'em.
And they takin' out stuff on women,
because they're not wanted,
and they feel like, we're stupid,
because if we knew how
to work this, we would.
But, no. 'Cause what you're
doin', is what we're doing.
It's just a different way.
And that's the problem,
because they feeling raped
and robbed of they souls.
Lotta them were takin' advantage of.
The rage, the vengeance,
is on the wrong people.
A lotta times you get treated bad,
because they can see in your
eyes that you can see 'em,
behind the veil.
- [Mark] What was the
best part of your life?
Best time of your life?
- When I was about seven,
in the second grade when we moved here,
before the molestin'
started here, in California.
I won a contest for how you
keep your keys safe. (chuckles)
So they gave this great big old trophy,
that was probably big as
me, in the shape of a key.
My teacher cared, so I
wanted to be a teacher.
- [Mark] Do you think that
the sexual abuse you had
from those four different
people, when you were very young,
may have changed the course of your life?
- Oh yeah. Because my mom and people knew,
and it was like they were allowin' us
to be just passed around.
- [Mark] Your parents knew?
- My mom. But then I found
out my mom was going through
a lot of incest and had been raped a lot,
and had a lot of illegal
abortions, by her uncles.
And she told me didn't
know how to help me,
she learned how to black it
out, she thought I would. Yeah.
- [Mark] If you could of changed
one thing about your life,
what would you of-
- What would I change?
- [Mark] What would you change?
- My choice.
- [Mark] To use?
- Yep.
- [Mark] Yeah.
(Joy sobs softly)
- [Mark] All right, Joy.
Well thank you for coming
in and talking with me
- Thank you.
- [Mark] And good luck getting clean.
I hope you turn the corner on this.
One day when you're done, you'll be done,
and you just turn your back and move on.
- Thank you, Mark. (laughs softly)
My tears are drying up.
Almost can't even cry no more.
I have moments, I might
get 'em to come back,
but can't even cry no more, that's it.
(sobs softly)
- [Mark] Let me get you
a room tonight, at least.
- What? (laughs softly)
- [Mark] Yeah, I'll
get you a room tonight.
- Oh my God.
- [Mark] You think after that I'm gonna
let you sleep on the street?
I can't do that.
- Wow. Thank you.
(mic clattering)
- [Mark] And a friend of Alicia's.
(Joy laughing)
How could I not take care of you?
- Oh my God.
- [Mark] Does that get you a room tonight?
- Oh my God. Yes, oh my God. Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, Jesus.
You both remind me of her. (laughs softly)
Y'all are some Daisy Duke's
with some boots. (laughs)
- [Mark] No, Alicia was great (indistinct)
- [Joy] Thank you. Thank you so much.
- [Mark] All right, then.
- [Joy] You have a great day.
- [Mark] You too.
Thank you, stop crying.
- [Joy] Bye.
- [Mark] Bye.